le geste est pathétique
l'heure est historique le champion du
monde d'échecs vient d'être battu en
combat très singulier par une machine il
était certain pourtant d'en venir à bout
cependant l'intelligence a dû laisser
place à la formidable puissance de
calcul stockés dans les laboratoires du
bm est implanté dans les entrailles d'un
ordinateur d'une tonne et demie doté
d'une logistique et d'un centre de
recherche aux moyens quasi illimités
l'homme après avoir tâtonné douter
souffert on avait plus que la sixième
partie pour prouver sa supériorité
il s'est incliné et ça n'est pas dans
ses habitudes
l'ogre de bakou d'ordinaire impassible a
dû aller jusqu'au bout de l'humiliation
il conteste à présent l'impartialité du
match pour lui les dés ont dû être pipés
je pense qu'il est temps tour dit bhl ou
de jouer au vrai échec et je peux vous
promettre à vous tous que si dit blues
jouent à la régulière je vous le
garantis je le réduis en pièces le
prodige français relève le défi kasparov
pour lui s'est trompé la machine n'est
pas imbattable
les bleues elles être franc on tels que
là c'est clair on dans la dernière
partie là où quand même une position qui
convenait à son style a t il fait aussi
beaucoup d'erreurs stratégiques ou non
dans les positions semblent côté
organisateurs on admet non sans peine
que la machine était ajustée après
chaque partie et la machine est fait
chaque jour rendue plus intelligent
quand on voit des problèmes à paraître
on corrige dans l'univers des échecs
c'est la première fois qu'un champion du
monde est battue par un ordinateur
futile surpuissant garry kasparov et
bien décidé à savoir comment la machine
là bas tu es aussi à prendre sa revanche